furthermore the very attempt to define
how a philosophical work is supposed to
be connected with other efforts to deal
with the same subject matter drags in an
extraneous concern what is really
important for the cognition of truth is
obscured the more conventional opinion
gets fixated on the antithesis of truth
and falsity the more it tends to expect
a given philosophical system to be
either accepted or contradicted hence it
finds only acceptance or rejection it
does not comprehend the diversity of
philosophical systems as the progressive
unfolding of truth but rather sees in
it's simple disagreements the body
disappears in the bursting forth of the
blossom and one might say that the
former is refuted by the latter
similarly when the fruit appears the
blossom is shown up in its turn as a
false manifestation of the plant and the
fruit now emerges is the truth of it
instead these forms are not just
distinguished from one another they also
supplant one another is mutually
incompatible yet at the same time
they're fluid nature makes the moments
of an organic unity in which they not
only do not conflict but in which each
is as necessary as the other and this
mutual necessity alone constitutes the
life of the whole he who rejects a
philosophical system that is the new
philosopher does not usually comprehend
what he is doing in this way and he who
grasps the contradiction between them
that is the historians of philosophy
does not as a general rule know how to
free it from its one-sidedness or
maintain it in its freedom by
recognizing the rest of the reciprocally
necessary moments that take shape as a
conflict and seeming incompatibility
one thing that philosophers will often
feel compelled to do or actually are
compelled by other people to do is to
clarify where they fit in to the history
of philosophy up until that point that
is to show where they fit in with the
other figures the other modes of thought
the other approaches and if you're if
you're contributing something new you
really need to explain not only how what
you're doing is different than what
other people are doing but why anyone
should listen to you why what you're
doing is advanced on other people so
Hegel himself is being asked like
everybody else to do this and he's
saying you know I really can't do that
effectively in a Prophecy's in' why
philosophy preface --is don't don't work
quite as well as they ought to so he
says the very attempt to define how a
philosophical work is going to be
connected with other efforts to deal
with the same subject matter
notice that could be not just a
philosophical works but depending on
what kind of philosopher you are that
could be works in cognitive science that
could be works in linguistics that could
be works in history that could be works
in religious studies or theology so long
as you have to clarify how you differ
from our advance upon provide a critique
of can respond to you know we could go
through a whole bunch of different
qualifications that way other people who
are doing the same thing there is going
to be some sort of issue here and he
says this is an extraneous concern and
it obscures the truth why well because
conventional ways of looking at things
get fixated on what he calls the
the antithesis between what we'll talk
about what antithesis means in a moment
between truth and falsity so let's just
take one example from front it will take
two examples from the history of
philosophy Plato or Aristotle which one
is right which is which one is true
which one is false well about what well
for example is there a form of the good
out there Plato thought that there was
Aristotle says no that that really
doesn't make sense so Plato looked like
he was true but really his position is
false and Aristotle's position is true
so if that's the case well why bother
reading Plato you're going to get
everything you need by reading say
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics where
he's criticizing the notion of a form
the good or the metaphysics and in a few
other things why bother with the Plato
well because this is actually a
superficial way of looking at things
it's a misguided way of looking at
things what would be another example
innate knowledge do we possess innate
knowledge the rationalist said yes at
least about certain things the
empiricist said no one of them is right
one of them is wrong we just need to
figure out which one is the case and
then we know which one to assign to the
dustbin of history and which one to
elevate on the pedestal of truth so
angle says no it's not really like that
the more conventional opinion the more
conventional way of doing things gets
fixated on this and I see a lot of
students that I see a lot of
interlocutors and I see a lot of
philosophers do this myself and they
tend to expect of a given philosophical
system to be either accepted accepted
or contradicted contradictive to buy
what contradicted by that which is
acceptance right so there is this
antithesis this blog on this either-or
set up a philosophical system not just
its parts but a whole system like say
platonism or Aristotelian ISM has to be
either accepted or contradicted and this
is a very dogmatic way of doing things
you know you could say well Aristotle
was a rejection of Plato and improvement
among Plato so we you know he
contradicted Plato and Plato is now in
the false position and then aerosol goes
along for a while and depending on which
history of philosophy you want to read
maybe it's the Stoics who we actually
take take on Aristotle and say no
aerosol is wrong about about this stuff
or it's the Aristotle of the Middle Ages
not actually the true Aristotle of
Middle Ages but Aristotle moribund
scholasticism which is rejected by the
early modern and Aristotle goes from
being accepted to the contradicted part
now we you know decart and and Spinoza
and Hobbes and people like that and
there Locke Hegel thinks no that's not
really the way to approach philosophy
and philosophical systems why we want to
think about what he calls the diversity
of philosophical systems there is always
a number of different alternatives at
least by the time that we're doing
philosophy available to us and even a
good intro to philosophy class should
introduce you to at least a few of these
on a few topics so how should we
understand this diversity is it just a
matter of these antitheses where
something is accepted for a while and
then it gets contradicted and now we get
me no longer bother with it and we have
to
get whatever new is accepted well what
if things go into a blind alley that
happens occasionally he's not actually
talking about this in this section but
we could think about are there times in
philosophy where philosophy actually
goes off course and can't adequately
even understand what its own business is
where it narrows its viewpoint a bit too
much so he says what we need to see
instead of this antithesis is we need to
see the diversity of philosophical
systems is what we call the progressive
unfolding of truth so another way of
putting this is development going from a
less mature state to a more mature state
to a more mature state and I suppose
what we should do is like you know start
adding things in to these to make them a
little bit more complex you know and
gradually the systems that are actually
making real progress in philosophy what
are they doing they're taking what was
true in the one before them and they're
holding on to it and they are
transforming it by way of integration or
what Hegel would call synthesis into
something new usually this is happening
by doing the Hegelian three-step shuffle
of you know thesis antithesis synthesis
by taking what's true taking looking at
what contradicts it seeing what's true
in that finding a way to bring those two
together and now you got a new stage and
you can keep on doing this as I said
there would be some some blind alleys
Hobbes for example might be a blind
alley in philosophy Peter Abelard as
opposed to Ansem might be more of a
blind alley than
in a handsome you know and some is
definitely a development over Augustine
and Gregory Aquinas would be an advance
past and some synthesizing by the way
Aquinas is theory of truth person he
talks about next to as much as Aristotle
and so bringing those together fusing
them and gradually we get more and more
well-developed
things in the history of philosophy so
he has this metaphor of the bud the bud
disappears in the bursting forth of the
blossom start with a bud and you know
buns are green usually right and then
they get a little tinged with the flower
and now we have this beautiful flower
showing forth and we think oh wow it's
done this is so wonderful but the flower
is just like the first step because
what's the point of a flower I mean this
is where where it gets really
interesting what's the point of a but
just to be a bud by itself no it's to
bring forth a leaf or in this case a
flower and what's the point of the
flower for us to cut it off and stick in
our houses and you know give to two
girlfriends and say isn't this wonderful
no it's a to produce something else to
be pollinated for them to exchange back
and forth and then what is that the end
of the picture no it's to produce fruit
and so the fruit is something very
different than the but he says the
blossom is shown up it is in its turn as
a false manifestation of the plant now
that the fruit emerges from it as the
truth of the plant that's what it was
all about and then we could go on from
there perhaps as well and in philosophy
we don't want to say well you know Plato
was just immature Alfred North Whitehead
here something along those lines instead
what we want to be able to do is
recognize what was being achieved what
was true in that and then what was the
next developmental stage
what was surpassed and what integrated
something from from that into it and
showed what the real meaning of it was
that's what Hagel thinks philosophy
dialectical philosophy developmental
philosophy is doing and so he says
there's an organic unity of the entire
process in which these these things
don't conflict they're not in a
antithetical relationship of truth and
falsity of that which is contradicted in
that which is being agreed with but
rather they're part of an organic unity
in which each is as uses this term
necessary the but is necessary at that
stage to lead to the flower and you're
not going to get a flower from a piece
of chalk all right you could get a
flower I suppose from a piece of paper
but it's not real flowers an origami
flower so this entire process is the
necessary unfolding of truth and he says
how do other people approach philosophy
they approach it this way and see it in
terms of these long-term added on
synthesizing developments no the person
who rejects the philosophical system
often doesn't comprehend what he's doing
in this way he just rejects it he
doesn't see what's really true in it and
then the person who does see the
contradiction between them levels them
out and treats them as if they're not
any process of development you know
really strictly speaking what I should
have done is draw this line going upward
because you're developing into higher
and higher states into something that is
greater and greater value and to a
certain extent greater and greater being
certainly greater and greater levels of
truth so
is that something that you can easily
roll into a preface can you show this
entire pattern of development no that's
why the preface is just a little bit of
a big thick book the rest of the work of
this development is taking place in the
rest of the book
demanding and supplying these
superficial explanations passes readily
enough as a concern with what is
essential where could the inner meaning
of a philosophical work find fuller
expressed expression then in its aims
and results and how could these be more
exactly known than by distinguishing
them from everything else the age brings
forth in this fear yeah when this
activity is taken from more than the
mere beginnings of cognition when it is
allowed to pass for actual cognition
then it should be reckoned as no more
than a device for evading the real issue
as a way of creating an impression of
hard work and serious commitment to the
problem well actually sparing once off
both for the real issue is not exhausted
by stating it as an aim but by carrying
it out nor is the result the actual
whole but rather the result together
with the process through which it came
about the aim by itself is a lifeless
Universal just as the guiding tendency
is a mere drive that is yet lacks an
actual existence and the bare result is
the corpse which has left the guiding
tendency behind it
similarly the specific difference of a
thing is rather its limit it is where
the thing stops or it is what the thing
is not the concern with a more results
with differentiating and passing
judgment on various thinkers is
therefore an easier task than it might
seem
for instead of getting involved in the
real issue this kind of activity is
always a way beyond it instead of
tearing with it and losing itself in it
this kind of knowing is forever grasping
at something new it remains essentially
preoccupied with itself instead of being
preoccupied with the real issue and
surrendering to it to judge a thing that
has substance and solid worth is quite
easy to comprehend it is much harder and
to blend judgment and comprehension in a
definitive description is the hardest
thing of all
so in Section three Hegel is going to
bring in a few other important concepts
a few other important themes and he's
already been engaging in criticism of
the sort of things that people want a
book of philosophy to do and want the
preface to do now he is criticizing yet
another mode of this and he's saying
these people who are just poncing around
think they're actually grasping the
essential what's the inner meaning of
the work of philosophy and this should
be something fairly easy to articulate
so how would you do that and he talks
about a couple different things you
could you could focus on in this section
a lot of times people will talk about
their their aims their goals of what it
is that their day and then the results
of it and Hegel says this is not by
itself great work there's nothing wrong
with aims there's nothing wrong with
focusing on results but these are not
going to be the entirety of what he
calls the real issue in German the Zakas
helps the thing the the matter itself
the real thing that it is that we're
concerned with and he says that this is
the idea people have where could the
inner meaning find fuller expression
than in the aims and results in what it
is that they're shooting for in what it
is that they actually do produce how
could these be more exactly known than
than by distinguishing them from
everything else that the age brings
forth in the sphere so you know
philosophy has different aims produces
different things it's not you know a
practical science it's not like the
other sciences which each have their own
subject area these would be you know
ways of going about this so he says when
the activity is taken for more than the
mere beginnings of cognition when it's
allowed to pass for actual cognition
then it's evading the thing in itself
because activity has to be engaging with
the real thing the real issue the real
phenomena that it is that we want to
study and we're going to see him talking
about this in just a moment first I want
to get on some of the things that he
says about aims and results and also
what he calls the guiding tendency he
says by stating the real issue as an aim
so for example if I'm interested in is
he's going to talk about later on power
relations the relationship between
master and slave or employee and an
employer you know under capitalism or
things like that that's the real issue
and it's not going to be exhausted by
just talking about what my goals are and
by achieving certain results in the
study it might my work may or may not be
adequate to what it is that I'm trying
to investigate here's one hint to by the
way about this adequacy thing one thing
that will make it more adequate is when
I take into account my own embroilment
in that that real issue when I don't
regard it as something purely external
and outside of myself when I don't
pretend to a kind of objectivity that
rules out the importance of subjectivity
but that's for later on so he says the
real issue is not exhausted by stating
it as an aim I want to study power
relations state saving you're going to
study power relations that's not the
same thing as actually doing it and in
philosophy as opposed to some other
fields where it's harder to get away
with biessing people that sort of stuff
there are many papers and even many
books where somebody says I'm going to
treat this topic exhaustively and I will
cover everything and I'll give you a
whole new viewpoint on it and you read
through and you're like man I was a
waste of my time I didn't actually
anything because there wasn't anything
new to learn there so merely saying that
you're going to do something is not the
same thing as actually doing it's not
the same thing as engaging with what it
is that you're supposed to be coming to
understand nor is the result the actual
whole the results are more real in a
certain respect that goals are but the
result is only what it is because of all
the rest of this so if the result
doesn't somehow contain that or retain
its relationship to that remember we're
talking about the world of thought here
then the results actually loses what it
was the result of so think for example
of histories of philosophy that just
tell you what people thought and maybe a
little bit about their arguments about
why they thought that but really contain
nothing of the mind of Descartes or the
mind of Spinoza or the mind of
Schopenhauer that's what differentiates
a good history of philosophy from a bad
history of philosophy by the way
philosophers are not just reducible to a
set of propositions expressed in their
works there are human minds and the
result has its value because of the
activity that goes into it so like he
says the aim by itself is a lifeless
Universal just as the guiding tendency
is a mere drive that has yet lacks an
actual existence the bare result of
beautiful mind is a corpse which has
left the guiding tendency behind the
drive what it was that made you want to
get into that in the first place
so then he goes and starts talking about
the specific difference of a thing and
what differentiates that thing from from
something else so he says this concern
with a more results with differentiating
and passing judge
is an easier task than might seem when
we're looking at the history of
philosophy it's very easy to sir
classifying people all these are the
empiricists and empiricists we all know
must think that everything comes from
experience directly well know as a
matter of fact Locke thinks that there
is an inner sense Hume thinks that
things do come from the outside as
impressions and then we work on them as
ideas so it's not quite so simple as
that as simple as the I don't want to
say Wikipedia because Wikipedia is
gotten a lot better but these the
sparknotes versions of things so what
should we be doing he says instead of
getting involved in the real issue this
sort of activity is always like shooting
beyond it instead of actually hunkering
down and sticking with it and
persevering these are not the terms
Hegel is using but they're pretty darn
close in meaning toward he talks about
tarrying that means you know that
tearing is a little bit more of a
leisured word that means they actually
like sticking around and seeing what
happens not saying oh you've got an
appointment gotta take off sorry
I'll read the the memo that'll tell me
all about what it is that we're talking
about here or just give me the outline
no you tarry with it if you really want
to know well you don't think about this
if we really want to know what Hegel is
talking about we don't say look we're
going to do a set of lectures on Hegel
it's going to be 20 hours and we'll pack
in these topics and if we don't get to
other stuff no big deal you know we're
going to get to the most essential bits
of it know if you really want to fully
understand a philosopher you have to
actually hang around with them you have
to linger you have to engage in the kind
of dialogue that becomes possible when
they become a companion to you some some
better companions and
I mean reading jeremy bentham is kind of
dry and dull stuff and sometimes that's
so it would cut to reading the card is
always a hell of a lot of fun and but
you know you might actually get more out
of reading well you won't get more out
reading Bentham or content a cart but
they're all pretty much on the same
level I would say and it goes the same
for Hegel as well if our work in doing
philosophy is the activity of thought
and we're trying to make sense out of
reality we don't want to shoot past it
we want to actually spend the amount of
time that it requires what this reminds
me of actually is when students will ask
me how much time should I be studying
for this class or how long should the
paper be then and you know before I
started giving them more prescriptive
guidelines I would say well the paper
needs to be as long as it needs to be to
actually adequately treat the subject
and of course that would bother them
because they would say well I have no
idea how long that is and I obviously
dr. Sandler you don't either because you
can't tell me in my case and I said well
you know I mean start writing and then
find out
that's what Hegel is calling calling
here tarrying tearing with the real
stuff
these akka zotkin zetas alps and seeing
what the phenomena actually reveals to
us so like he says at the very end of
this to judge the thing that a substance
in solid worth is quite easy it impinges
itself upon to comprehend it as much
harder what are you doing when you
comprehend think of it as wrapping when
we tie we have this metaphor I need to
wrap my mind around something imagine
that your mind is an articulate organ
and it can wrap itself with all these
tendrils around the thing that you're
studying and that that thing probably
has got some tendrils of its own that
are that are going to sort of get
tangled up with your mind that's a
comprehension tease that's very
different than passing any quick
judgment or classifying something or
saying I know what box to put this in